thank you very much professor P sedative
facilities for having said they sing so
nicely you came up on the optimistic
side on automation robotics
technological innovation actually we had
last year opposition took between
optimists and pessimists and at the end
of the day I think the optimists got the
larger support from the from the room so
you are one of them
you mentioned Maynard Keynes and what
you disagree with there's a lot to agree
with actually we're discovering the
great master nowadays but when he was
talking about the economic prospects for
our grandchildren which actually is now
it's us in a sensible talking his own
way to increase the growth which is what
we are talking about today so thank you
very much Chris for this great
introduction and now we move to a
novelty in the process economic forum we
start with a new TED talk type which we
have dubbed broader horizons it is the
opportunity to indeed bruton our reasons
and cast the net wider try to bring
fresh thinking to to our our reflection
so I'm extremely pleased to have to
delay here Stephanie Stan Trevor
who has accepted to kick off this new
initiative stephanie is a professor of
economics at Harvard University she has
worked a lot on
taxation innovation but it's this new
generation of economists which associate
the same rigorous empirical analysis to
account to an approach to economics
which actually broader than the classic
ones so I think very happy to have you
here
you have worked on taxation its taxation
and innovation but also on the interplay
between immigration attitude to
redistribution so I think is you are the
perfect fit for the agenda of today
Stephanie is well known she was this
year actually named by the Le Monde and
the circle des economists as the best
young economist of the year and last
year I recalled that the economists
named her as one of the top young
economists of the of the decade so I
think you have your credential you know
well set stephanie has a PhD MIT she was
born in Bulgaria but completed she lived
in France she moved in France when she
was very young
she'd complete a degree in in the
Cambridge in France at the Ecole
Polytechnique then MIT doctorate and
then hard work today I have to say a
little anecdote we had last week the
Eurogroup meeting and the Eurogroup
every now and then deals with thematic
topics
it was together with talking about Italy
SEM and other lesser less glamorous
issues and the thematic issue law last
week was on innovation
inclusive growth and inequality and the
guest was Philippa Gyan who is a
colleague at Harvard of Stephanie and in
the round of enhancing the round of
questions by ministers being put a bit
under pressure he told them when you go
back home what you should do is to look
at the papers by sniffing Eastern Java
because there you will find the answer
so how you design the tax system to
foster innovation in a durable way so I
was I was very happy to see that we had
the right intuition in inviting
Stephanie here with us and we are very
happy she has accepted to kick off the
broader horizon talk a big applause of
Stephanie thank you
[Music]
great thank you marker for this very
generous introduction thank you all for
being here I'm very excited to be giving
this inaugural TED style talk so when I
was asked to give this test I'll talk I
did what I guess we would all do which
is to go in Google how do you give a
good TED style talk and one of the top
tips that comes up is try not to be too
academic which you know for someone
who's actually an academic is a great
start but I did not get discouraged and
I kept reading the advice and the second
big advice is focus on only one big idea
15 full minutes one idea wait who really
has time for that I know you're all very
busy people hard pressed for time you're
very smart and important I want to make
use of these 15 minutes that we have so
I'm going to try to offer you you know
all the brand new and exciting research
results that I can possibly fit in and
so if you're ready let's get started
if there is one overarching idea I would
like to talk about today it's that we
need to listen more to people and by we
I mean researchers and policy makers and
when I say people I will mean all of us
in our capacity as citizens across all
the layers of society and I don't mean
this in an idealistic or wishful you
know open your hearts open your minds
kind of way that's very nice to know I
actually mean listening to people as a
rigorous research method and as a tool a
new tool for science and policy and that
tool is surveys of people surveys means
asking people questions directly and how
should these surveys be now there should
be you know well-designed well
calibrated intuitive clear interactive
well targeted to representative samples
or specific groups and they can be done
online at a very large scale to get
responses very quickly and what can
these surveys bring us what's their
value well there are things which are
intangible and that we really cannot see
in any other data
unless we ask people directly even in
this day and age of big data and what
are those things well there's three of
them one is people's perceptions
perceptions about others perceptions of
themselves of the economic system of
economic policies the second is people's
views of fairness what is fair what is
equitable and the third is people's own
economic circumstances so these are very
important things why well first when we
decide which policies to support as
citizens these things definitely matter
you know our perceptions our views of
fairness and our own economic
circumstances and when we want to think
which policies will work and how best to
design some policies these are also
extremely relevant things and the third
perhaps scarier reason is that there is
a group of people that is already
listening to people's perceptions and
catering to them and pretending to offer
solutions and that's populist and so we
need to listen as well and hopefully
offer much much better solutions okay so
in this talk I want to go through these
three big topics and give you some brand
new results from research what we can
learn from surveys about these
intangible things and what we can do
more so let me start with the first big
issue we need to ask people about their
perceptions their perceptions of others
of themselves of the economic system and
of economic policies so let me start
with people's perceptions of others and
in fact with a particular group of
others which is immigrants so we did
this large-scale surveys and six
countries eliciting people's views about
immigrants and many have suggested that
you know generosity unfortunately
perhaps does not travel well across
ethnic national and religious lines and
that part of the reason support for the
welfare system as we know it is fraying
is because people think it mostly
benefits immigrants and immigrants will
you know be the be the winners from it
but in fact people have very very
inaccurate views about immigrants
so the first inaccurate view which I'm
going to show you with a little graph
here is what do people know about how
many immigrants are actually in their
country
so these are the six countries in this
study and the blue little stick man or
and women show the actual number out of
hundred people in that country who are
immigrants the yellow showed the
perceptions in that country so you see
that in all countries people absolutely
starkly overestimate a share of
immigrants and it doesn't really stop
there people think there's way more
Muslim immigrants than there are people
think immigrants are much more weak
economically than is the truth they
think people you know immigrants are
less educated poor more likely to be
unemployed more reliant on government
transfers etc and you may say ok but
surely more educated people do not have
you know these misperceptions in fact
everyone is wrong it's just that some
groups are more wrong than others so
people who actually work in low-skilled
sectors with a lot of immigrant workers
people without a college education and
people to the right of the political
spectrum have much larger inaccurate
misperceptions about immigrants but
everyone is wrong and why does this
matter well it matters because if you
just make people think about immigrants
before asking them policy questions you
see that people will support less
progressive lesser distributive policies
by just thinking about immigrants so
this is really really important the
second big type of perceptions we would
like to know is what people know about
themselves and people can be wrong about
themselves too about their economic
position and their rank and society so
I'm going to tell you about a new study
in Denmark in Scandinavian countries
such as Denmark there's this great
ability to match administrative data
such as tax returns to survey data so we
know both what people think
and we also know their actual
circumstances so we know in detail their
incomes the incomes of the neighbors of
people in their municipality of people
and their firms etc in case there's
people from Denmark fear not this data
is fully anonymous and non identifiable
and so we can compare people's views
about themselves where they rank to
reality and what do we find
and what we find is that
the rich really overestimate how rich
everyone else is the rich really don't
know how poor the poor are and vice
versa the poor think everyone is poorer
than they actually are so the poor
really don't know how rich the rich are
and when you ask rich people and poor
people to rank themselves relative to
others rich people tend to rank
themselves much lower than they truly
are and so this is very important
because our own perceived circumstances
really shape our views on policies the
third pick you know issue for
misperceptions is what people know about
the economic system now tell you about a
specific aspect that I just studied
recently which is what do people know
about social mobility so why social
mobility is so important
well how fair we think the system is and
how much equality of opportunity there
is really shapes how much equality of
outcomes we want or how much inequality
were happy to tolerate we're okay
tolerating more inequality of outcomes
if we think the path that there was fair
and again people have quite wrong views
about mobility actually so let me show
you here on this graph on the horizontal
axis it shows you the true probability
of a kid that's born in the bottom of
the income distribution to make it to
sorry to remain in the lower quintile
and the lower bottom of the distribution
when it grows up and it shows you the
average in each country so for instance
in the u.s. around 33 kids out of 100
born in the bottom quintile will remain
there when they grow up in Europe things
are actually better than in the US
according to this metric kids born at
the bottom will have more chances of
making it out but on the whole on the
vertical axis I show you the average
perception about that probability in the
countries and I've marked in blue with a
you know thunder storm cloud pessimistic
the upper panel which shows you people
overestimate the chance of a kid staying
stuck in poverty
so that's in Europe people tend to be
too pessimistic relative to reality
about mobility you can also look at the
mirror image of this which is what is
the chance of the American dream or the
European dream which is really
what is the chance of making it from the
very bottom quintile to the very top so
that's shown on this graph we and the
horizontal axis is the reality and the
vertical axis is the average perception
here you see that again European
countries are mildly pessimistic and the
u.s. is really over optimistic in the US
this notion of the American Dream is
really very salient in people's minds
although it may no longer be a reality
and so people really overestimate this
chance of making it from rags to riches
what about the other final fourth type
of misperception which is about economic
policy and misunderstanding of it
there's a lot of economic policies which
affect us in everyday life
tax policy trade policy health policy
and yet you know we often misunderstand
them and may support or oppose policies
without truly understanding the
implications on ourselves or others so
there is work on that too and what we
can see for instance just to give you a
few examples people tend to starkly
underestimate the income level at which
the top tax rate kicks in so they think
the top tax rate affects many more
people than is actually the reality
similarly for the estate tax in the US
people think that 40% of all states pay
the estate tax when in fact the reality
is 0.7% and so they think moderately
wealthy people already pay the estate
tax that many small businesses and small
farms pay it which could partially
explain you know the strong opposition
against the estate tax and just telling
people the reality increases support for
this policy similarly one thing which we
may all be confused about is who are top
incomes well we tend to think according
to survey data that it's a lot of
entrepreneurs you know the Elon Musk's
Mark Zuckerberg of this world that it's
a lot of stars in the media and sports
even scientists know I wish but in fact
we tend to underestimate the true share
of managers executives lawyers doctors
people working in finance ok so there's
a lot of misperceptions that people have
and possibly shaping their views on
policies and that we could potentially
correct with better information
the second big issue that we should ask
people about is their views on fairness
and people have quite complex user
what is fair what's not without asking
it's very hard to know because it's
complex and its context dependent and so
what do we learn about views on fairness
from all these surveys
well we earn we learn a lot I'm gonna
restrain myself to just two examples and
you know by introspection see how you
feel about these issues so contrary to
how our tax system perhaps acts in
reality people tend to think that you
know it's fair to tax away an income
that was not earned through hard work
for instance you know if you get passive
returns on on a fortune that you have if
you inherit wealth it's fair to tax that
then someone who's been hard working for
their income if you got lucky on the
stock market then it's it's much fair in
people's minds to tax that away
another big fairness consideration and
which shows the complexity of this is do
people think these state taxes fair is
it fair to tax inheritances and bequests
well it's quite complicated actually
because if you ask people is it fair
that parents can give their wealth on to
their kids most people will say yes you
know these parents saved they work for
it if you ask is it fair that kids start
with different wealth and income in
their life most people will say no but
these are you know two sides of the same
coin so clearly we need to ask more we
need to understand more and come to you
know some agreement so the key is to
understand these fairness perceptions so
that we can aggregate them through a
fair policy debate and the final big
thing that we should ask people about is
their own economic circumstances and to
be very clear there's a lot of things we
can see in other data which I will call
non survey data
what's this data well you know
administrative datasets tax returns
Social Security records retail scan data
that shows people's purchases etc etc
there is many other data sources and we
can see a lot of things there what I'm
saying is we should also use survey data
to see the things which are really
invisible in these other data sets about
people's economic circumstances I'm
going to give you two very concrete
examples to make this clear the first
example comes from the US and I truly
hope it's irrelevant for Europe which is
that in the u.s. you know many parents
don't have generous enough health
insurance or no
health insurance and so when their kids
get ill especially for kids with serious
conditions the sometimes wait in the
parking lot with the kids in the car
next to the emergency room you know to
be there in case things escalate but do
not have to pay in case things are ok to
go into the emergency room so if you
look at health records
that's for instance one type of non
survey data what you would see is that
well you know kids go to the emergency
room when it's warrant it all seems fine
right
but this would be very hard to figure
out if you did not ask doctors or
parents directly you would never know
what happens in the parking lot and the
huge cost in terms of time worry risk
taken in this situation
another example perhaps closer closer to
home is fuel taxes and carbon taxes on
households proposed in many countries
implemented in some with you know big
consequences the fuel tax economic
theory says will do its desired job
which is to reduce fuel consumption only
if people can switch away from fuel
right if they can switch to alternative
modes of transportation for instance
like to the bus and so if you just look
at transportation data you may say great
there's a great net you know bus network
in the city no problem to have a fuel
tax people will switch but if you survey
people you may soon notice well the bus
schedules stop before the night shifts
start for night workers or people need
to also drop their kids off at school at
the same time with some complicated
route or the doctors live way outside of
the bus network etc another thing you
can say is look at the transport date
and say well nobody is switching to the
bus that means the fuel tax is too low
we should increase it but when people
cannot respond such a tax that's
supposed to be corrective becomes a pure
negative transfer from people that hurts
people and so you the right answer would
not be here to try to increase the fuel
tax but the right answer would be to try
to understand what are the constraints
that prevent people from switching and
to be clear climate change is such an
urgent issue and we need to so urgently
take action for it that perhaps the
direct way of trying to directly go and
understand the situation is the quickest
most effective way that could you know
prevent us from reaching misleading
conclusions if we do not use survey data
as people so you know I want to end up
again by reiterating that I think we
should listen more to people we as
researchers and policymakers and you
know their perceptions of others of
themselves or economic policies of the
economic system their views on fairness
their own economic circumstances and
surveys are a great tool for research
and for data-driven policies because if
we don't listen you know others will and
those are populist parties and they
pretend you know to understand these
concerns and to cater to them offer good
solutions but if we use survey data in
addition to our other tools and data
survey data on how people think feel and
live I think we can propose much better
policy solutions thank you very much